- [Voiceover] Graph
0.6 on the number line.
Down here we have a number
line that goes from zero to one
and it's split into one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
nine, 10 equal spaces.
These tick marks, there's
10 of these spaces
all the way from zero to one.
So between any two of these spaces,
for example, between these
first two tick marks,
could be represented by 1/10.
It's one, one of the 10 equal spaces.
It's 1/10 of the distance.
Now the number we're
supposed to graph is 0.6.
Well this six is in
the tenths place value,
so another way we could read this decimal
is 6 tenths, or as the fraction, 6/10.
So if one of these spaces
represents one out of 10
equal spaces, and we want 6/10,
then we need to travel six
of the 10 equal spaces,
6/10 of the way.
Six of the 10 spaces.
So we can start at the
beginning and go one, two,
three, four, five, six.
And graph right here with
a point and this is 6/10.